I had more five-inch worm-like specimens
after continuing with the H. Pilari program
and the RIFS person shared that with us a couple weeks ago.
Should I start the D. Wormer?
I bought from you and how should I use it?
So if you're talking about the Fed Bend is all
that you, if you got it from our store,
comes three little packets in there.
That's a week's worth.
So just do it three days in a row, one packet per day.
You could mix it in your smoothie.
It did take it that way, just one packet a day
for three days, then off for four days.
That's how I would think.
Also my emotions have been all over the place
since this has been going on.
Well, there is some emotional issues with passing parasites
for some people because they're like,
oh my gosh, it's just the anxiety
of the passing parasites.
But then there also has been cases
where passing parasites can affect us
from an emotional perspective,
because it is affected a certain part of our brain,
the what's called the amygdala of the brain,
where you actually hold a lot of your,
how to put it, memories that have a lot of emotional content
and usually those are negative memories.
So like memories of difficult situations.
My mother died when I was seven or I was abused
when I was 10 or I broke my leg and I couldn't play
my senior year of soccer.
There's things that have an emotional charge to it.
And there is data out there that passing parasites
can bring those up.
And I'm not sure the neurological connection to that,
that to sit down and kind of figure that out,
but there is some truth to that.
So.